[Music]
connecting your zeros why is this man
carrying a giant cowbell into a diner I
mean who's gonna get Kevin an award
Dunkin Donuts big guy described a slow
likes donuts cliche
I guess America's easiest insults run on
Dunkin it's fit we'll handle the
stretching from vaguely funny named
jokes around here recycled Scott why are
the desks pressed together when there is
clearly a lot of floor space for the
employees to spread out and have a
little more privacy could the answer be
camera angles TMI too much information
I used to say don't go there but that's
blame I know right she's making me look
through hours of footage to find
highlights meaning you were being paid
to watch ridiculous tapes all day
instead of having to perform your
mundane receptionist responsibilities
cry me a frickin river Pam it was - who
are we laughing at um just something
somebody wrote who dave barry dave barry
the writers on this show don't only do
cringe humor they also understand
character based humor and that's a
perfect Dwight joke if ever I heard
anyone sure Michael's a dunderhead but
this is a dick move by Jamm this is like
the 8th year right and he's been getting
this budget approval for all previous
years so why few just telling him this
now talk to you for a second about that
also with all the conversations Michael
has allowed the schlocky Metairie crew
to stay in the room for I kicked them
out over this simple misunderstanding
also also did they leave the boom mic
guy in there Michael clearly isn't
wearing a wireless lapel so how are we
hearing him with such consistent clarity
I mean maybe they installed a permanent
wired mic in each room and was always
recording but I'm gonna pull out Occam's
razor here and just assume lazy writing
tripple also if Michael wants privacy
why not close all the blunts did he
forget what he was doing halfway through
just for the benefit of the TV audience
it was the o5o 5:05 party it happens
once every billion years the standard
was one party a year and Michael has
already had two why is this conversation
just now happening the done
award for longest engagement goes to Pam
Beesly and of course we got some dundies
position about Pam's love life because
god forbid we go even five minutes on
the show without checking in with what's
going on with as the Pam turns the Jim
in the painless Jim roll pan spittle and
how the jokes are really bad cinemasins
critics I think if you use the same
jokes it just comes across as lazy
cinemasins critics can someone explain
the Chili's logo to me why the hell did
they connect the H in the L o it does is
make it look like the restaurants
actually named GG's plus I'm pretty sure
that first I is getting forced into a
three-way it did not consent to the
dundies are kind of like a kid's
birthday party and you go and there's
really nothing for you to do there don't
listen to this guy there are plenty of
great things to do at kids birthday
parties but not only can you eat chunks
of icing off the cake and blame the kids
you can also show them there for
cinemasins video so they develop a
well-rounded sense of humor
why would Pam immediately take Ryan's
seat when she comes back inside and why
would Ryan relocate to create Meredith's
day plot convenience that's why this
woman is reacting to Michael Scott doing
a grotesquely racist caricature of an
Asian man complete with costume teeth
and eyes there's hasn't aged well
and then there's age so overtly racist
that an [ __ ] a YouTube channel that
nitpicks other people's hard work for a
living doesn't even feel comfortable
showing it well this is the latter also
these other [ __ ] stayed and watched
and eventually cheered him on sure you
can tell me Michael's just a clueless
imbecile but the problem in hindsight is
that it's now obvious what a collection
of enabling monsters the rest of the
office is for not calling him out on
this thing those might be empty
no no cuz the ice melts and then it's
like a second drink except there isn't
any ice in these glasses so they are in
fact empty it's for the time that I went
to the bathroom after him and it was
really really smelly crap but also did
you notice the woman seemingly collapsed
on the floor even if you know she's just
drunk perhaps show some concern for her
as well also where was this [ __ ]
manager when people were throwing food
at his customers a few minutes ago your
patrons can Chuck white spinach queso at
each other but you get on this guy for
trying to save a life by taking off his
shirt free the nipple
great work tonight
Rochester excellent yes great work blah
blah blah can we get to the real juice
of this episode and tell me who paid for
this party the sound equipment all the
little trophies had to cost something
right was it Michael why would the show
set this plot lineup if it never
intended to pay at all the B story
plotline bill is due and I need to know
why no one signed the check I award you
no points and may God have mercy on your
soul
employee smell something terrible coming
from neighbor's house won't you smell
like cheese now Stanley is a Dundee
all-star understand watch you show them
some of your bling in America it's bling
bling but out here it's bling bang huh
so what's the joke ding dong who's there
you me try get the door I'm not
answering answer ding dong no way Jackie
jeffing doll I just wanted to say that
the women in this office are terrible
I'm saying that you're being sexist
no I'm being misogynistic this says
bushiest beaver thank you
I just had it stuffed the germans
nickname for me is the little man that's
the least of my concerns right now i
want to own a decommissioned lighthouse
and i want to live at the top and nobody
knows i live there and there's a button
that I can press and launch that
lighthouse into space